[موسيقى]
بعد شد وجذب يعترف نعم لقد خسرنا المدينه
والمستشار الالماني يحضر رساله قويه
لروسيا فما الذي تحمله الرساله
نهجكم محفوف بالمخاطر وهذا اخر تحذير
ومجلس الدوما يبدا رده القاسي على بولندا
والطباخ بوتين يعود بصيامه مجددا نحو
الخونه في بلاده ومجموعه سبعه تتخذ قرارا
عسكريا ضد الصين فكيف سترد بكين الاحتلال
ينتهك حرمه المسجد الاقصى والمقاومه ترد
بقوه وبين ايران وباكستان حرب الحدود
تندلع
الانتحار الاوروبي
انتشع الغبار لينجلي الضباب في اوكرانيا
ولتجوب اخبار الخساره الشرق
والغربها الرئيس الاوكراني
صريحه
باقيه في قلوبنا نعم اعترف بان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه خسرت مدينه بخمت وذلك
على هامش قمه مجموعه سبع هيروشيما حيث كان
قد رد على سؤالي عما اذا كانت بخموت لا
تزال تحت سيطره الجيش الاوكراني ليعترف
بفقدانها حسب رويترز لكن
وبرغم اعترافه قد زعم بان الجنود
الاوكراني لا يزالون في بخمه ليرد قائد
فاجنر قائلا بانه لا يوجد ولا حتى عسكري
اوكراني واحد في المركز السكني مضيفا زلل
اكذب او انه لا يعرف ما يحدث على الارض
لكن على الجانب الاخر وفي ضواحي بخمته لا
تزال القوات الاوكرانيه لم تطوي صفحه ضخمه
بعد حيث ان التصريحات صادره عن قيادتها
تتقاطع مع حديث الرئيس حول المدينه
بقيادات الجيش الاوكراني يقولون بان
القتال لا يزال مستمرا وداريا في ضخمه
خصوصا وان قوتك تحاول تطويق المدينه من
الجنوب والغرب لترد الدين للقوات الروسيه
التي حاصرت الاوكران في ازوفيستال فهل
ينجح الاوكران بخلطتهم هذه ام ان للروس
رايا اخر ليجيب المتحدث باسم قياده
العمليات الشرقيه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
في بخموتك اصبح اشكاليا وان الانسحاب من
المدينه سيتم عاجلا اماجلا وكان شرباتي قد
نفى ان تكون قوه فاغمر سيطرت على بخمه
وقال ان القوات الاوكرانيه تصد هجمات في
جنوب غربي المدينه فكيف غيرت حديثك من فوز
الى خساره بين ليله وضحاها يا هذا ومع
الاعترافات الاوكرانيه جاءت دور على طباخ
بوتين ليدلي باعترافه ايضا نعم هناك قائد
مجموعه
يقول ان عدد قواته كان يجب ان يبلغ ثلاثه
وعشرين ضعفا لحجمها الحالي وفقا لمنهجيه
الحسابات العمليه والتكتيكيه التي اقرتها
هيئه الاركان الروسيه وارجع بريغو جلدك
الى ما سماه الخيانه فعن اي خيانه يتحدث
وفي سياق اخر اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عن تحيد عشر مجموعات تخريب واستطلاع
اوكراني على مختلف محاور القتال واعتراض
15 من صواريخ انظمه هاي مارس
واورغانو خلال يوم
ومن حرب المدافع والبارود الى معارك الغرب
مع الروس لكن عن بعد حيث قال المستشار
الالماني في حديث النقلات صعبه
ان تدريب طيارين اوكران على قياده
واستخدام مقاتلات من طراز 16 سيكون رساله
لروسيا ليرد نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
بان موسكو ستاخذ بعين الاعتبار ضمن خططها
نيه الغرب تزويد اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16
وتاما جروشك الدول الغربيه بمواصله السير
على نهج تصعيد الصراع في اوكرانيا مؤكدا
انه نهج محفوف بمخاطرها اله على تلك الدول
نفسها في مقاله الخارجيه الروسيه ان
الولايات المتحده تشن حربا هجينه ضد روسيا
والمنطقه باكملها واضافتنا واشنطن تضللل
وتنافق بقولها انها ستمنح اوكرانيا طائرات
اف 16 شرطه عدم لضرب روسيا وبعد كل هذا
المخاض العسير الذي تخوده الولايات
المتحده واوكرانيا لمواجهه الدب الروسي
اعتبرت هلال وزيره الخارجيه الامريكيه
السابقه والمرشحه في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
عام 2016 ان فوز في انتخابات 2024 سيكون
نهايه
في امريكا ايضا بحسب
ومن اوكرانيا الى بولندا بدا خصوم روسيا
بالتكاثر ومع تصاعد التوتر بين موسكو
وارسو قال رئيس مجلس الدوم الروسي
ان المجلس ينظر في موضوع اتخاذ اجراءات ضد
بولندا بما في ذلك عبور الشاحنات عبر
اراضي روسيا وشرف لودن الى ان بولندا
تتحمل في هذه الحاله خسائر قد تصل الى
ثمانيه مليارات ونصف المليار يورو وفق ما
اوردته وسائل اعلام روسيه الاح والتطورات
بعد القمه الاخيره هي دول مجموعه السبع
اتفقت على اتخاذ رد عسكري موحد ضد الصين
حاله اتخاذها اي عمل عسكري ضد تايوان
دفاعا عن الاخيره وكان قاده السبع قد
اقروا في قمتهم المنعقده في اليابان
عقوبات جديده على روسيا على خلفيه حربها
على اوكرانيا وشملت العقوبات قيودا على
صادرات سلع مثل الالماس وحرمان موسكو من
التكنولوجيه والمعدات الصناعيه بما تعهد
القاده في مسوده البيان الختامي للقمه
بتقليص الاعتماد على التجاره مع الصين
الخارجيه الاردنيه تحذر من تصعيد خطير
وذلك ردا على اقتحام بنغفر للاقصى لان ذلك
يمثل خرقا للقانون وللوضع التاريخي للقدس
وفق الوزاره الاردنيه من جهه اخرى وفي
خطوه مفاجئه اجتمع رئيس وزراء الكيان
بنيامين نتنياهو بحكومته في نفق تحت
المسجد الاقصى المبارك وذلك بعد ساعات
قليله من اقتحام بن غفير باحات المسجد
الشريف ماثر ادانات واسعه فلسطينيه وعربيه
واسلاميه فيما نفذت المقاومه عمليه داس
على جنود الاحتلال في بلده حوارات جنوب
نابلس ارتفع عدد المشردين في مدينه
وهي احدى اغلى المدن في امريكا بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار السكن ووفقا للبيانات
الرسميه للعام الماضي يعيش حوالي مليونان
و580 الف شخص في الشوارع في الولايات
المتحده تتصدر ولايه كاليفورنيا القائمه
باكبر عدد من المشردين منذ اكثر من عقد
ذكر موقع ميزان اونلاين التابع للسلطه
القضائيه الايرانيه ان سته من حرس الحدود
قتلوا خلال هجوم في سروان في محافظه
سيستان الحدوديه مع باكستان وفي سياق اخر
كشف وزير الاستخبارات الايراني انه تم
اعتقال مجموعه ارهابيه مرتبطه باسرائيل
على الحدود الغربيه للبلاد
مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه يكبر يوما بعد
يوم برايكم هل ستستطيع هذه المقاتلات اذا
ما وصلت لاوكرانيا حسم المعارك ضد القوات
الروسيه
[موسيقى]